welcome to this video aqaba in the house
13 games 10 wins three losses and then
yeah we had some of those games were in
there we're here in the Scotch splaying
this really quickly yeah we have to
exactly that and I was thinking back
then that this is just nothing for white
but he he does not agree it seems um
let's see d5 maybe or not yeah d 5 is a
solid choice but ok let's do it let's
try not to get into huge time pressure
ok I can also go here for the IQ p90x d5
immediately was also possible but this
shouldn't be a bad i QP position for me
it's also not terrible for wide I mean
it sir it should be ok but definitely
this is one of the better i QP positions
for for for black for the side playing
against it as white has already traded
off two sets of minor pieces let's see
maybe here i am to get we should be six
or the tempo I can play d5 I forgot
about that maybe you should play ok d5 i
have c 6 trying to I can take
interesting but I think he should
consider d5 here yeah c6 he can take
Queen d2 takes on b7 that's not great
hmm
how do I play may be here on d6 I want
to play c6 mostly I mean here I can also
take but before yeah probably i will
take take off rooks soon ok chats let's
trade stuff shouldn't be shouldn't be
bad for me now I d5 is leading nowhere
it's mostly a self pin and you can trade
everything like Knight b6 and so on or
maybe you cannot even you have looked
takes Queen takes Knight b6 I have
Queenie one which leads to some nasty
pins
yeah I'm not sure what you should do
maybe route you one or something or 93
is also not bad Black is comfortable
here not sure what Y term should do I
also sometimes have Queen a for making
sure to trade even more stuff and I'm
really add on the clock that's not
happening that on yeah I thought that
Bishop before should be okay now let's
do that not over over think things
yes counter ticking counter-attacking c7
yeah this is this is definitely enough
counterplay form for wide
I don't have any great ideas here to be
honest just making some look for the
king it's probably just just about equal
the whole thing g6 also intends maybe to
play age 5 at the right moment they are
threads nowhere some Queen 85 maybe but
it shouldn't be too too threatening
really a six maybe not sure
yeah maybe maybe play that it's not not
a huge huge thing and I wonder ever
should put the night on d6 I can do that
it's not a bad idea maybe where we are
you going with this rogue okay
it's not really leading to much
is this some something that I can do or
is it really just equal
I mean I have everything nicely
protected it's all safe save and sound
but nothing really to do a five b6 this
a better structure I don't know maybe
maybe I can do that so at least then
only c7 is potentially attacked and I
can move the night now maybe I can put
the night on c5 it could be an IDM the
night on c5 might be something but you
can play with g6 all the time so maybe I
should advance here first now go here
let's subtract annoying for him so I'm
porn up but his King is far more active
now not far more active but it is more
active I can go here into your form time
morning
maybe I should activate the king I'm not
sure about this it's not difficult check
playing for this idea to actually have
the more active King check okay the
Chechen yes this check on c6 check or
this one even check
check
yeah nothing that I can do ready game
drawn oh yeah I habit okay maybe the
draw is just the right result I wasn't
sure him check I mean the round here I
probably should have something but I of
course Kia King King to be seven this is
much easier okay but maybe maybe taking
a silly all right now I went to take hmm
now I need to go here of course yeah
this is much better this is much better
because it does not allow king d three I
can still take yeah this is this was my
mistake it's really wondering dad this
is how I need to do it can't compare
this no this is much better here I'm
really just a pawn up and can go from
there okay so this the the obvious
capture was the problem yeah no it is it
is really tricky yeah I was I wasn't
really liking the look of that and this
is why I went with this idea that when
my King gets activated check but um yeah
check I should probably I should play
here of course play of six that's may be
easier but he has definite come to play
against my pawns in any case check check
yeah it's a moot point to to analyze
here probably it really is a draw it was
a very solid very area
yeah simplified kind of game all the
time maybe rookie for wasn't such a
great idea yeah but I had the winning
winning possibility I just need to play
King to 36 instead of grabbing
immediately this is really a huge
difference okay a draw at the end thanks
for watching